Remember the question I
just asked: "What
percentage of stores do you chase
after, and what percentage do
you come to practically right through the front door?"
The answers I received
only ranged between 80/20 and 90/10
.  If you can invest this time to
make your business into one that investors
chase, rather than just forging it,
then you are playing with the odds of winning,
rather than exploiting them.    Yes
.  And I think we should
n't really say that.
This is Dalton Plus Michael, and today
we're going to talk about a very simple and
easy topic: How to
win.
That's it.
Win easily.
Win easily.  How to win.
One of the triggers for this was that
we talked a lot about leverage at YC
.  In every situation,
you need to understand whether you
have leverage or not.
Yes, it's the question behind the question,
to which we've been asked many questions
, such as...  B. "How do I set up a good
round?"  or “How do I hire
good people?”  or whatever you
call them, very general questions.
What should be in my pitch deck?
And I thought that wasn't a very
useful question.
No.
Instead, I interrupted her and
asked, "Well, how much influence do
you have?"    Yes
.  Yes.
And the answer to the question of how much
influence you have had much more
weight on the actual issue
they were asking about.    Yes
.
than having a better pitch deck
or running a better process
.  And so the influence came up in
every consultation, right?  So why do
n't you define it?  Yes,
it's interesting to
think about how to
define influence, because I would like to
define it almost the opposite way.  I think that
the most formative experiences for
most of the young founders we've
worked with were school
.  And when you think about schools
, most schools are structured in such a way
that no influence is needed.
Most schools are set up in such a way that
people are very willing to help.    Yes
.  That's
their job.  In a sense, they are investing
in you with time,
attention, and materials.  And I
would say the expectation of a
return is very low.  And I think
when these people come into the startup world
, they want to create the same analogy in their minds
.  It's like,
"Oh, the investors are
here to support me, like
my teachers. They give me the money
I need to do things. My
clients will work with me
because they help me achieve my goals
, right? It's all as if
they're at the center of the universe.
Exactly." And I think a lot of what
we had to do at YC was
say, "No, this is a different
world. This is a world where you have to have
something of value." I
would say leverage is
basically about looking at the audience you're
interacting with and
asking if you're bringing something of value
. Are you asking for more value than
you can offer? Are you delivering more value
than you're asking for? And when it comes to
fundraising, it's always so
frustrating because you're wondering, "
Is this the right title for the slide?
" And then it's just the wrong
setting.
The whole framework
was like this: “No, no, no, no.
Why are we talking about the title of the
slides?
Are you growing?
Yes, exactly.
How fast are you growing?
If you're growing fast enough,
you might not even need this presentation
. If you're not growing and you're not
getting to market, then working
on this presentation could be
the biggest waste of time in many ways
. And the idea that the
presentation does the work isn't true
. The presentation does
n't do the work at all.
And so you're all in the know, we'll go into a bit more
detail in a moment, but I
think the real framework for all of you
watching this is to familiarize yourselves with
this leverage terminology
.
Yes. And learn to ask yourselves in every
negotiation situation: How
much leverage do I have?
And what can I do to bring more
leverage to the negotiating table
? Because negotiating is ten times
easier when you have leverage.
Yes.
Leverage is also another way of
thinking about it; it
's your ability to pull back
.
Yes, how urgently do you need
something to happen?
Yes.
And the more urgently you need it to happen…  The more leverage you need, the
less leverage you have.
Exactly.
Right?
So let's go through a few topics. Let's start at the very
beginning. We've
already
touched on fundraising, but let's quickly
recap it. How would you
view fundraising in the context of leverage?
It's one of the most
misunderstood aspects of Y
Combinator.
I think by people who aren't involved
.
Yeah. Are
you ready? I think some people
think Y Combinator is a
fundraising school where you get
accepted and the partners spend
three months teaching you how to
pitch,
creating a presentation, and
building hype. It's like a university
for fundraising.
We wouldn't have made it if that's all it was about
.
I would never have heard of it. Yeah, we would
n't have spent a decade working in this
place. That's
literally the worst.
That's a dystopia, okay?
The week and a half we had to do
was
painful enough.
Yeah.
What do you think? You see people
saying, "Wait a minute, isn't that it?
"  I'm sure some
people are watching and thinking, "What are
these guys talking about? Of course it is
."    No no no.
It's exactly
as Paul Graham said: to
be very effective at fundraising,
you have to grow so fast and have so much
evidence that your
startup works.    Yes
.
that you can be really bad at
fundraising, but still
put in very little effort and do so
in a very short time.
And that, contrary to intuition, it
is much more effective not to
prepare for fundraising at all and
simply do it intuitively in the end
, rather than dealing with extensive preparation
.
If you invest this additional time in
building, launching, talking
to users, and growth
.
So it is much better to be a really
bad fundraiser who
achieves something that works than
someone who is really good at fundraising
but achieves something that does
n't work at all.
Especially because investors see so many
pitches.  It's as if you think,
"Yes, we could help you
improve the language in your deck,"
but after the thousandth pitch,
the investor sees that he's already good at that
.  Do you know what you could be really good at
?  To develop a good product
.
And that's what I've been thinking about all along
, both in relation to
Standard Capital and YC, but I
would also think about non-YC companies
, how many hours they would
spend raising funds
.  Yes,
a seed funding round.    Yes
.
And if they
spent those hours working on their startup
, how much more value would have been
created in the world?  Based on the information
you provide,
we can make an estimate.  And once again
, dear viewers, if you have
ever raised money before, how
long did it take?  And what would
you have preferred to do with that time?  And
how much more value would have been created in your life
if you had spent that time somewhere else
?  I mean, it's crazy.
I remember one of the times
we almost died at Justin.tv
.  I had spent the previous eight months
raising funds.    Yes
.
And we worked hard every month.
And when it became abundantly clear that
we wouldn't be able to raise any money,
we only had two months.  And it was
okay, we need to figure out how to
make this profitable,
or we will fail.  And the
amount of [ __ ] we
've done in these two months, compared
to all the beating around the bush, and that
's the thing, as you know, we
love investors.  But if you only
think about how much time is
wasted, it's like a
burden on the industry.  Yes,
to have a capital raising method with low leverage.  Again,
basically there's no
way it's going to work
, but you just spend months
and months and months pitching.    Yes
.
And you would have been much better off
if you hadn't done that.
Instead of raising any of these funds,
try to grow your startup
.    Yes
.
And that's another part of what
I like about what we
do with Standard, that we can't
finance everyone.  We will not fund most of the people
who apply to Standard
.  But I know
in my heart that I
can calculate how much time they spent on the
application and how much time they
spent on the interview
.    Yes
.
And I have no problem with that.
Well, I think to myself, cool.  I'm setting
an upper limit.    Yes
.  Yes.
And I think that's a really
good thing, and I wish more
investors would do that.    Yes
.  They would be more careful
with the founders' time.
I think that was one of the advantages
of YC, which has been publicly known for over 20 years
and has not been
copied.
And it's so strange because that's just how it
is.  This cannot be described as a secret
advantage.
Yes, it's strange, isn't it?  I think
people on both sides really want to
believe that
if you
spend a lot of time with a company
that isn't really growing, you'll still invest.  Do
you understand what I mean?  I think both
sides believe in
this romantic notion.
Secure.
That there is more subtlety that
cannot be achieved in just a few meetings
.  And again, maybe, but that
's certainly not a bet I would take
.
In this situation, I would say
that everyone is being tortured to
find the rough diamond.    Yes
.
Yes, it causes a
net loss
across the entire industry, so to speak.    Yes
.
Because, as you know as a VC,
you invest most of your time in traction.  And
most of the time you're chasing after something – I've been
asked this often.
The Dark Game theory states that
many founders are kept waiting for months
because the investor wants to see
if they are actually growing.
Boom.
It's like buying an option
.  So if I just
hold endless meetings with this founder
and pretend we're investing
, and when it all starts, I'm well
positioned to do it.  So if you
proceed this way, you
unfortunately waste as much of his time as possible
.  You try to make him feel like
you're going to invest, and you meet
with him for months.
But this process harms his
ability to create this intellectual property
.  I
am completely against that.    Yes
.  That's funny, because we had
that moment with Social Cam where we were
practically the number two app in the App
Store.  And that's a leverage effect,
right?  And I remember
our pitch decks were hilarious.
One of our pitch decks
simply stated: “Here are some
questions you can ask us.
Here are all the statistics we
track, in the top right corner. What else can we
show you?”  But I remember
thinking at the time
that we had
major problems raising
funds just through television and Twitch.  I would like to
conduct a small case study.
Because these investors are going to
tell me [ __ ] now, since they all
want to invest.  And I remember
the question I just
asked: "What percentage of the
deals do you chase? And what
percentage of the deals come right
through your front door?"  And the
answers I received
only ranged between 80/20 and 90/10.  And it
's just as you say, if you
can invest that time to
make your company something
investors chase instead of
making cards, then you're playing with the
odds instead of gambling with the odds
.    Yes
.  And again, I think we should
n't say that.  I'm pretty
sure that... No, I think the
VCs would be really angry.  Because they
think to themselves: "Oh, that means
they won't show up."
Basically, the hope that
they might invest if you
meet with them often is a
hope that motivates them to do so.
I don't think they want that.
I believe the older, more
experienced people would prefer it if
someone only came when they
had leverage.
That's correct.  I'm just trying to
say that I don't think we should
n't say that.
OK.  Um, well, anyway,
you know. We didn't
tell you.
Yeah, don't listen.    Let's talk
about sales, because I
think that people, especially in the
beginning, have a misconception about
how sales
impacts the business.  What are your
thoughts on sales?
I think it's the same deal where
a founder who hasn't sold much yet
says, "Oh, I
got a cold email from someone who's
very interested in my product
. We've done it
. I just need to
close this one deal, and then I'm good to
go.
Riding off into the sunset."  And
you can't just need a deal
.
High leverage has the advantage that
you have so many customers that you
can be selective.    Let
me give you another example.    Let's say
someone launches a new
product,
and you receive a thousand sign-ups.
You can segment these registrations into
different customer types
and say, "I don't think
we'll start a business."
I don't think we will do that
.
You can
segment it and then decide
who you want to serve and all that
good stuff.  Conversely, if you
receive no registrations and there is really only
one potential customer you
can win, you put all your eggs in one basket
.    Yes
.
And that has all these really bad
secondary effects,
yes.
Where you don't know if you're close to PMF
.  Perhaps this one customer is
strange.    Yes
.    They
are too busy
making custom things for him.    Yes
.
As if they know they have one
.    Yes
.  One may be moving
further away from the
product's marketability without realizing it.  You know
, it's interesting because I think
that many founders don't
think too much about sales before they start their company
.  And they realize how important
he is when they try to turn this curve
upwards.
Interestingly, many
founders I speak to find it very
difficult to do more publicity
, get more meetings
and bring more deals into the funnel
when they are on the verge of closing a hot deal
they desperately
want to do.  I think they're telling themselves
that everything else will be
easy once they land this deal
.  Or they tell themselves
: "I'm working so hard on this deal
, but I don't have time."  In
reality, you
probably only work hard in your mind,
but you only attend one meeting per
week.  So it's not like
you're really working hard.
The definition of leverage in
this situation is almost as if
you didn't care if a deal fell through.
Boom.  Really?
Boom.
Correct?  If the deal falls through, oh,
we have eight more in the
pipeline.  These three call me every
day.
Yes, oh, I mean, I'm sad
that one of them burst.  Oh, well, good
heavens.
Yes, that's no
big deal.    Yes
.
This way you know whether you have the power in sales
or not.    Exactly
.  And if you don't
do enough public relations, you wo
n't be in this position.  On
the other hand, I would say that if you
are a customer, you don't want to
feel that the company
you are considering needs you more
than you need it.
That's not a good feeling.  And to apply this
to the topic of
negotiations once again: If you
have the power, then of course you can
be more aggressive in your pricing.  Of course you can't
give them discounts.  Of course you can get them
to sign a contract
and not a
letter of intent.  All of this depends on
how urgently you needed this deal
.    Yes
.
And when companies are doing really well
, you often see them
fire some of their customers who aren't in the ICP
.  Where they say: “Hey, I know
you pay us a lot of money, but we
can no longer serve you because
you want feature XYZ, which simply is
n't on the roadmap.”    Yes
.
That's a high leverage effect.  A
very high leverage effect.
The way to become good at negotiating in
sales is
not to need every single deal,
but to learn a few cheesy
negotiation tactics.    Yes
.
Oh, let's negotiate this contract
– let's close this contract until we
drop.  That's
not what this is about.
Correct?  Let's talk about hiring.
I think everyone understands that I need all
these really talented people
, but Anthropic is going to
pay them a certain amount of money.  OpenAI will
pay them such and such a lot.  But how
can I exert influence in a hiring situation
?
I think that when I look at the
hiring pipeline of founders
, the biggest problem is
that they don't have a pipeline.
Mhm.
They have so few candidates at every stage of the pipeline
.
Mhm.
that if they actually
find someone good through a miracle, they
have absolutely no influence.
Mhm.
And it is not clear where this person would have
joined them.  For example, if you need to
hire two engineers
, I don't know,
mhm.
Ideally, you would have a thousand possible
candidates and then subject 50 of them to
an initial review, and so on and so
forth. This way you have choices
.  So if a candidate
decides not to work with you,
or if someone asks for something you ca
n't give them, that's fine
.
You think to yourself: “Okay, fine.”  In
contrast, if there really are no
other candidates, they've
essentially dragged you into the negotiation, have
n't they?
When I think about it, that's
interesting.  I'd like to start with something
inspiring.  I think
many founders often believe they are
competing directly with Google.  One
has to ask whether the type of person
who would accept a job at a company
with 75,000 employees
is the same as the type of person who would accept the job
as one of the first ten employees
at a startup.  I
would say that there are some
overlaps, but they are
much smaller than one might think.  It is
therefore quite possible, even
likely, that especially
in the initial phase you will find yourself in a different
pool of applicants than you think.    Yes
.
And they are probably competing with
another startup in its
early stages, not with Google.  We
should make sure people
feel ten times better, right?  It is
easier to gain an advantage over the other
startup in the initial phase
.  I think
another thing to consider, if you put yourself in their shoes, is
that the
people you want to hire are looking forward
to this adventure with a big
impact, where they
can take control.
This can also be used if you
are much smaller.  You can tell them about all the
responsibilities they will have
.  And if they give you a strange
look, then that's not right?
And when they say, "You give me the
keys to this whole thing,"
then it's like this: "Yes."  I think
another thing is that one can talk about
the biggest challenges
.  And when they say, "
Oh yes, that's great for me."
If they say, "Oh, that could
mean that I..." you mean the
website will be offline over the weekend?
Then it is like this: "Yes."  So I think you
have more influence than you
think if you want to hire people
who are excited about the adventure
.  You have far less influence
than you think when you're looking for someone
who says, "I want to get involved in an
Open AI pre-IPO."  I
created a plan with the least amount of work and the highest amount of money.
Perhaps one more thing I'd
like to add:
If founders ask me about hiring practices
, I would ask them how much
effort they put into it.  And I
actually think that if attitude
is a big problem, if you have BMF or
whatever behind you,
you should probably put just as much effort into it
as into sales.  And
I think many people find that
shocking, right?  Okay, maybe
someone will say, "Yes, yes, yes Dalton, I
know."  They are shocked to
hear that just as much
emotional energy has to be put into hiring
as into acquiring customers
.  Because essentially, you're selling a job
within your company.  Therefore,
a sales process must be carried out.
All the advice we
just gave about sales must
also be applied to hiring.  It
's not like I have to
place a job advertisement.  Why is no
one applying?
That's not easy.  That's something
my former co-founder
Justin taught me.  He was a
great recruiter, and
I remember so many parts of
our recruitment process where
Justin and Emmett literally
discussed what a
great process would look like.
One thing we did that
I thought was simply brilliant was that
if someone was good, we received a
printed and signed
offer letter.  This was
then handed to them at the end of their final
job interview.
And we had a pre-arranged
drink or dinner.  They extended
an invitation.  It was simply this:
Yes.
It was like, as you
say when selling, when we know
we like this person, we
go to the loft.  And it wasn't as if
the recruiter would contact you in a
week, or that we
had to gather our notes
and didn't know what was going on.
Instead, this process has given you
an impression of what
it would be like to work at the company
.  And
if you are good at these things,
you will win this way.    Yes
.
They have more influence and gain an advantage
over other recruitment agencies, just as
we've just said.
They make the offer on the same
day, and the other startup does
n't understand what's going on.  If you
simply do all of that, you've won.    Yes
.
Correct?  And these aren't ninja tricks
,
no.  At the very
end of the negotiation process, the focus shifts to better
negotiations.  It's about all the
preliminary work you've done to create
a high-
leverage situation.
Finally, would you like to
talk about marketing and PR?
Yes, I believe you know that there is
an issue here.  It keeps coming back
.  Over the years, we've
noticed that too many founders were obsessed with getting press coverage
.  I thought to myself, “
Man, if I could just get
the New York Times or
TechCrunch to write about me.”  That
was it…Well,
let's start with that and then think to ourselves,
"Okay, if I can get
TechCrunch to write about me,
then I've made it."  One
funny thing is that we
tracked this and the founders had us tell them
how many clicks,
sign-ups, or customers they got through
advertising for…  And it
's shocking how little press
helps a startup.  Shocking.
It is specifically directly measurable.    Yes
.
Like registrations, right?
It's great because your parents will see it
.  There are other cool things that come with
receiving an item.    Yes
.
But if you think, "Okay, cool, we
got the article," and you
think to yourself, "Let's take a
look at your dashboard."  That was
very disappointing for the founders.
Can I explain that in more detail?
I spoke with the editor of a
popular blogging platform
.  He told me that we would selectively enable or disable paywalls for
startups like Startup Stories
.
And if we believe it's
something people
actually want to read,
we'll of course deactivate the paywall.  If not,
we'll activate the paywall because we
know that the PR person
helping them and the
five subscribers...
subscribers will get them because they
want to read this article and
need to subscribe.  And I think to myself:
"Oh, this poor founder is
basically feeding their business model
with this blog."
Yes, they generate about 10 sign-ups
for a paid blog.    Yes
.
And they expect this to have a positive impact
on their company.  They're just
burning money.
And here again, the
leverage is low, friends.  If
you think, "I need someone to
tell my story."    Yes
.
High leverage:
Tell your own damn
story.  That means
simply posting all the time,
constantly.    Yes
.  Over
and over and over again.
And to have no guards present.
Post content that you yourself would want to
consume.  Correct?  This
also has to do with sales.  If I
read your outgoing emails,
would you kill the company that
sent them, or
would you reply?  The same applies
to your content, right?  If you
produce content that you
want to consume yourself, bam.  It's all
ok.
You get leverage.  And I
think that's relatively
new.  I mean, the last 5 to 10
years?  Otherwise, the
best approach before was
to tell your story in the press.
And now I would almost say that
this is the anti-best practice.
Uh, that's meta.  It's like breaking the
fourth wall, but like this video series
we started making,
why are we doing this?  I think we
were genuinely not convinced
that the stories we
wanted to tell would be adequately expressed
if we didn't simply
step in front of the camera.    What
if we were guests in someone else's pre-show?
That would be
like a lame, fake controversy
along the lines of "I heard
the YC batches are big and yeah,
that would be [ __ ]."  And so we
realized that the only way
to tell our own story and
connect with the audience is to
simply do our own
thing.    Yes
.
You should do that too, audience.
Well, I think people are always
surprised by how much it
costs.  Um, but it creates value.  I
would also say that they are the same
muscles used in fundraising,
recruitment, and
telling your story
.  It turns out that these
muscles are used in many different places
within a startup.  It
's not for nothing to train these muscles
, because there is a direct
channel to potential users, so
they know that you are the face of the
company and that you
are the person who will help them.
That is
very valuable.  In summary,
winning is about
how much influence you have.  It's
not about how much nonsense people
tell you.  In all these
situations, a
startup might feel like it doesn't have much
influence.  But there are often
a lot of things you can do to
increase your influence, especially
towards other startups.  Above all.
And it's usually the preliminary work.
This is
not the final hearing.  It's
all the work you've done beforehand that means
you've
already won by the time you start negotiating
.
You think to yourself: “It’s over, I
’ve won.”
It's funny when you think about Usain Bolt
.  How much work is done in the 10
seconds of this race?
More than zero.
But there are
years when you
simply can't accomplish that much in 10 seconds,
compared to all the work that goes into it beforehand
.  Okay, great chat
, Dalton.
Thanks.